تداول نشاط نشطاء على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو للحظه عقد قران
بفتاه من اندونيسيا بملابس الاحرام في
مطافي الحرف حرم المكي وظهرت في الفيديو
رده فعل العروس حيث لم تتمالك نفسها
وانهمرت دموعها وسط فرحه المحيطين بهما
[موسيقى]
تداول المشطه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مقطع فيديو يظهروا امراه وهي تتشبت بغطاء
سياره مسرعه لمسافه اربعين كيلو مترا في
تركيا لمنع طليقها من الهروب بابنها
ووسائل اعلام تركيا ذكرت ان الشرطه تمكنت
من التوقيف السائق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انتشر مقطع فيديو متداول لكاميرتي مراقبه
يظهر سقوط رجل على مركبه في روسيا وافادت
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه انه سقط من الطابق
التاسع عشر من المبنى لكنه نجا وتلقى
العلاج دون ذكر سبب السقوط
[موسيقى]
فيديو انتشر كالنار في الهشيم لام عراقيه
تنهال بالضرب على المدرسات في مدينه
البصره البصره العراقيه وعند البحث عن
الاسباب تبين ان الام اتت للدفاع عن
ابنتها التي طردت من الصف بسبب وضع كمامات
مع صديقاتها وذلك بهدف اخفاء المكياج
لاحقا اعلنت وزاره التربيه والتعليم صدور
اوامر بالقبض على السيده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يلا
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء